CBS News confirms White House
communications director hope Hicks is
expected to testify on Capitol Hill
tomorrow about Russia she is one of the
president's longest-serving advisors and
former White House chief strategist
Steve Bannon has agreed to an interview
with Special Counsel Robert Muller he
refused to answer many questions at a
congressional hearing on Tuesday but a
source tells CBS News Bannon will answer
anything that Muller asked him major
Garrett is at the White House major good
morning good morning president Trump
will campaign later on this afternoon in
Pennsylvania in advance of a special
house election there and a year that
already looks turbulent possibly
dangerous for the president and his
Republican Party at least as the
midterms are concerned the president's
mind might also be on Steve Bannon that
a strange former White House ally who is
expected to testify again before the
House Intelligence Committee today I
think we've been dealing with this hoax
for the better part of a year White
House press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders repeated the administration's
assertion that the Russia investigation
is a waste of time if we have to endure
the ridiculousness for another month we
can certainly handle it but the drumbeat
of current and former Trump
administration officials testifying
before the House Intelligence Committee
has picked up speed in recent days White
House communications director hope Hicks
is expected to appear tomorrow former
chief strategist Steve Bannon could be
back before the committee today his
second time this week while former
campaign manager Corey Lewandowski and
deputy chief of staff Rick Dearborn both
went before the committee yesterday
bannon's testimony on Tuesday irritated
both Republicans and Democrats
Steve Bannon refused to answer any
questions after the campaign but sources
tell CBS News Bannon has agreed to
cooperate with Special Counsel robert
muller and he will quote tell-all White
House lawyer ty Cobbs told the CBS
podcast the take out that Muller will
also likely get a chance to interview
the president the president is very
eager to sit down
and explain whatever is responsive to
the questions but Cobb is concerned mr.
Trump could perjure himself you have any
fear of a perjury trap no but I think
it'd be I think it would be foolish to
you know not proceed without considering
that possibility cop told us he believes
the Muller investigation will be over in
four to six weeks acknowledging he's
made that prediction beforehand been
wrong the difference this time Cobb told
us is that he believes Muller is quote
desperately trying to bring this to an
honorable conclusion unquote gale a lot
of people hope that's the case
thank you very much major